let's big update coming in yasa that
there is a queen sacrifice on the board
the knights that we were talking about
wly so what is happening here when we
left it we saw the position after Bishop
to D6 and shame on us uh well NE medov
is not in studio but his Spirit lives on
Peter yeah this is a very very
interesting sacrifice and apparently a
correct one as well it doesn't win but
it definitely is very playable it's
Peter before we go deep dive let's just
get our head around this that it's Queen
for a knight two minor pieces ah Queen
for two minor pieces yeah because n
medov was famous for sacrificing his
Queen for two minor pieces yes we're
going to pick the bishop on he's going
to pick up the bishop at the moment it's
Queen takes nine which is just for one
piece but it comes back with a check on
F5 and picks up the bishop on D exactly
so we get a pawn and two minor pieces
this is completely unplayable because
this costs like more pieces